[Music]
so yeah this is basically what it's
going to be just like the grid
layout um
i
took the colors
actually from the app
the hex colors so they're actually the
hex colors
and
yeah basically also changing this
input to be down here
just make it a little bit closer to what
the actual app is
so
we can stop this
cool and so
basically when going through this like
seeing the original
app i always use testy for some reason
because test is not five letters
um right
winston built it with a verbatim text
output which is easy um and good
um but if we want to style it we're
gonna start wanting to get it into
like html dom elements
and so basically taking this result
output here and instead of having it be
verbatim text output we're going to do
ui
output
output
call it result also
comma now we can get rid of this
verbatim text output
and so that
itself
should work it just doesn't give you the
knight it's just like text
but that works just replacing that
um but
what we eventually want to do
is get it into a bunch of individual dip
so that we can put you know a nice
border around each letter color it do
all that stuff
so right now
the way that it works
output result is a render text we're
going to need to change that
and
looks like there's a v apply that makes
a character so it's basically assuming
it's a character vector
and then it pastes everything together
here
so
what we are going to do
is
make this not a v apply
but an l apply
so that it can just be a list
by doing that we need to get rid of this
and then format result just to like
make sure it's working we can just wrap
it in the div tags div
function
save that we can run it
but
it gives us this output
and that's just because we're still
doing this paste here
so
we can get rid of that
by just returning
out sdr
reload it
now we're getting an error
that's because like i said we need to
change this
because right now render text is trying
to paste everything together because it
says i'm putting out text
and we're just giving it a list of divs
so that's not going to work
now it's working
this is a div we can check that though
to make sure
just do like an inline style
i like to do outline like is my default
like
check to see if something's working so i
do outline one pixel solid salmon
because it's my favorite css color
and so we see
we are indeed getting a div the div has
the
whole guess in it
so we can do shiny as our second guess
so we get two divs they're stacking on
top of each other that's good
pretty much what we want
but in here the div body is still just
this text pasted together so we should
update
format result because div takes that as
the input
so we need to make this not return just
a string but return
a list of divs
so
we can do this by right now it's
loops in a for loop over the letters in
a given
uh guess
and so builds this out str so we're
going to replace out str without
divs
we make that a tag list which is
basically just a fancy list that
is works well with the tags like div and
stuff
and then in here
you can say out divs
the ith element is going to be equal to
a new div
is
this internal
section here
so we can pull that out
here's
the braces there and then last
this one
just has spaces
get rid of all of these out strings
i have just returned out oops
and so
in theory
this should now
yep so now it's behaving differently
because by default divs
themselves like to
stack on top of each other they don't go
inline it's uh
because they're a block level css
element so that basically says the next
one going down instead of over
but um one of the things that we can do
here
is
put some style around this so we could
say
instead of making a bunch of divs we
could just do this one time bring this
down here
and have
this if statement give us the inside
text it would say like
letter
text
equals that
and then just bring these back to pastes
[Music]
so the idea here is to
do a single
not that
do a single div call
um
so that way we can do stuff like put a
class on it without having to repeat
that class like a million times
so that should be good we don't need to
do the assignment here
these assignments
so then once we've assigned letter text
in this
in that this
if statement
assigns letter checks based on how we
did the result
so that we can just take that letter
text and put it in this div just quickly
make sure it worked
okay looks like it worked
we
so
do some inline styles here
so we'll do outline one pixel solid
blanched almond is another good css
color
okay so now we can see we have this
wrapping div
each individual letter within here is
taken up the whole span that's because
of these block elements so
i think
a good way to proceed
since we want that grid we want them to
sit next to each other
just try with
50 pixels height
50 pixels
just see what this gives us
okay so they're boxes now
but they're still stacked
so i guess if we wanted to make them
sit next to each other like they should
there's a few different ways we can do
this
i think the way that i want to do it
just because i am
familiar with it is to use css grid
so css grid is basically a way of saying
you know i want you to lay this stuff
out um in a different
way and you can say like you know i want
to fill in this many columns and this
many rows and so this works really well
here because we know we have five
columns
and so
we can start doing that but first we
should probably
like right now we're building our styles
and these inline styles and that works
fine for just like a couple things but
it's going to get pretty un
like unwieldy
very quickly
um so what we can do
is include some css and there's a bunch
of different ways
to do this
um
the easiest way
is to just put the stuff in the head of
the
ui so it's tags dollar head
says anything that goes within this gets
placed into the head of the ui uh html
that's generated which
kind of
part of the page that doesn't actually
show up but you can put resources like
css and javascript in there it doesn't
really matter uh just know that you have
to put your style so you can do
tags.style
within that
and then from there there's one one more
thing you have to remember and this
bites me like
every time i do this is that you have to
wrap
this because we're going to write it in
text inline to wrap it in this html
function and that just allows us to use
um characters that css likes such as the
like
uh
less than or greater than signs
uh which would by default get translated
into like weird unicode character things
but css actually wants them
so we need to wrap it in html or we will
have very confusing bugs
that will take a long time to
understand so
in theory tags head tag style now we can
just start writing css in there and
it'll apply to our page
um so we can test that again by
targeting this result because ui output
creates a
div that shoves all of your ui into it
and the id of that is the id that you
give it um
so we can target that real quick let's
say
css rule targeting targeting result and
say
let's see background color
which is another since we're already
using outlines let's use background
color and for background color we can do
light gray
leave that's the right way so see if
this works
did not okay so background color light
gray is probably not the right one
let's just do steel blue
there we go okay
so
this is div result which contains
all of our stuff as background so we're
successfully targeting it with this um
css rule so what we're going to do
is go back and do this css grid stuff
so that we can get it to lay out how we
want it to because we have each letter
being a div
we want them to
sit five next to each other and then
wrap down to the next row so for each
guess
so we could do display
grid which is how you say like okay this
div
within it use the grid
layout engine um and then we can do
grid template
columns
repeat so we're saying repeat this thing
five times five and 50 pixels so that's
saying
make me a grid that has
columns that are defined as 5
columns of 50 pixels this is a syntax
that's kind of
hard to understand and i know it because
i work with it all the time but there's
a really good
resource
uh which is this complete guide to css
grid
uh which is where i go for almost
everything uh it gives you all sorts of
things so if you ever forget
anything with css grid this is a
fantastic resource for it
so
i'm going back here
we're saying it's going to be a grid
it's going to have 5 columns
each 50 pixels wide so we can save and
reload
and it's not doing what we want it to
but interestingly
there is a border around this that is
the color
that we put of this div um
that's right it's the salmon border and
so
we actually don't want that div we just
want the results
dumped right in there so we can just get
rid of that div in general so that all
of our
um
yeah there we go so we are wrapping it
in a div and css grid says
um i'm gonna you know i don't know about
the children i only care about the first
child i don't care about the children of
your children
uh so the div within it
will be a column and then the next one
is another column and so on but right in
the way that we were doing it we were
wrapping all of the letters in a single
div and so i didn't actually know to put
them how we want them but
now it is and so now we see the
five
values in their little boxes here
we can do another guess just to see if
it wraps how we want it to let's get
shiny
it does so now we have five
new guests down here five
and all we're doing is building these
divs and so
what we should do now is obviously this
text is up in the upper left and that's
not great um
so we need to target these individual
divs and before what we were doing is
this in-line styles
but that's not great so we're going to
take that out and bring it back up to
our
css chunk
so
we could call
there's a couple ways we could do this
we could say we could give this div a
class itself and then refer to that
class up here
or we could
say
result and then
div
which is saying like of all of the divs
that are children of result this is the
style i want to apply
but i think that what we want to do is
make a new class just be a little bit
more readable so we could say
guess
letter
we're going to paste in that style that
we had before
save that we need to go down here
and put the div class in but let's run
it without that first just to see
so yeah we get they're laid out in that
order but they don't have this style so
now in theory to get that style back we
should just say class equals
guess
letter
so that should give this div the class
of guest letter
so that should apply this so let's see
if that works
did okay cool so now
we want to style these guys we could
just do it right there which is nice
so within that we could say you know
let's first thing i think we're going to
want to do is put this
actual letter in the center of the box
so it's not wasting all that space so
there's a bunch of different ways to
center something in css it's like kind
of
like the uh
one of those problems in computer
science along with like caching uh
aligning stuff in css but
the easiest way to do it that i'm aware
of is to do display
grid so say this this child element also
has a display grid
and then place content
center and that basically just
centers everything completely within the
div
so now we have everything perfectly
centered so that's nice so it's starting
to look a little bit better
one thing that we can do
uh to make it a little bit more like the
wordle thing is have them not butt it up
right against each other uh so there's a
property
on the grid css grid it's called gap
so you can say gap it'll set it to like
five pixels so that's basically saying
place these
items of the grid 5 pixels away from
each other
cool so now they have that gap it's
getting better
we can round the edges a little bit and
say
border radius
also say that's five pixels so that
should just say
i'm gonna round the edges oop but i did
it wrong
oh you know what i need to do order not
outline
border radius border
there we go
border
on newer browsers the outline will
respect this border radius but on
older browsers such as the built-in
viewer in rstudio you need to use the
border
which is kind of confusing that there's
border and outline but
just
there is at this point
um
so now that we have
that things are looking pretty good
um
stuff is working but i think the next
step is going to be
right now we're using this indicator of
like wrapped in parentheses means that
it's in the wrong place but in the word
and then square brackets mean that it's
correct
um so
that's probably not the best way to do
that given that the actual wordle app
does it in color so we should start
doing it in color
and we're going to do that
with
another class
so
if we notice this down here
the way that our results come each thing
has a result
it's either correct
inward
or
not in word
and so if we use that we can use that
directly as a class on our
div itself so
within here format result
class is going to be paste
of guest letter and then also
the result itself
and that
we
reload the app i'm going to pop this out
into the
browser real quick so that we can use
the inspect panel just to see if this is
working
so we can see now
this element here this
s
has a is a div with the class of guess
dash letter and in dash word
so now that we have that class we can
use our css like we were doing before to
target it
and uh make it look how it should so we
could just say
dot in word
and i believe let's see in the
wordle app he uses like an orange
uh that's we could say
inward background color
is orange
red
a little bit more intense than we maybe
want but
let's try that
cool so now
that's colored correctly
there's the not in word i believe is the
other class that we have
yeah not in words so
the other
letters here
not inward
background
color
it's called light gray i think i did it
right this time where light gray does
not have a hyphen
let's fix this indentation
but it's just one single word
wonderful
so we can get rid of that border that's
getting really distracting
and then we should probably
say color
is white and color on a element
confusingly not the background color
that's set with background color or
background color is the color of the
text
so this should
when we have these
darker background colors we kind of want
white uh maybe gray is not the right
color we should use something
darker
just pure gray
okay so now we see the letter pops out a
little bit i think we should increase
the size of the
font a little bit so do font size maybe
make it 20 pixels
cool looking better um
we still have this like decoration here
actually we should figure out a letter
that is in the correct place
why is that not a valid
guess oh it's not a valid word is it
interesting
stop s has to be at the end
interesting okay s is sitting here
but hidden because i haven't styled it
fun
so correct i think is the style we need
to give it
correct yes okay so now
that
can be done background color
do forest green that's a good one
reload app
test
wonderful
still have this
um let's see if we can figure out a word
that has
let's just do shiny to see
okay so we still have this like
decoration there so we need to get rid
of that or we should get rid of that
just to make it
look nicer
the nice thing about
this is that this whole if loop that we
were doing here before we don't need it
all because we just need the letter so
we can just take that letter
put it there and get rid of that
so
simpler code
reload the app
wonderful so that is starting to
actually look like
the correct stuff which is nice
so
i guess one thing that we need to fix
now
is the fact that uh this legend doesn't
mean anything anymore um so we should
fix that
so
this is just text here
this means that the letter is correct
so
what we can do is we can use a span
element
class equals
guest
letter
okay and i think that this is going to
be a little bit much though
because
i will say it means the letter is
correct so correct
this is going to make this 50 by 50 and
that's not what we want
yeah
so that's a little bit too big
so we should figure out how to get this
sizing not
specifically
tied to
that so all the sizing stuff
with 50 pixels height 50 pixels font
size 20 pixels we only want that to
apply to this result board but we still
want to be able to use this other stuff
down here
so i'm going to use the css
rule that i
talked about before which is we could
say
of the result
anything that is a child of it that has
the
uh
class guest letter
um there we can put these styles and
that means those styles should
only apply to the guest letters that are
a child of this results div
but we get this now that's not great
um
[Music]
probably also want to put this
grid stuff here
okay there we go
so now
x is still not great
um so maybe we should do padding
uh
four pixels
padding just basically says like give me
some space around the content within
this
element so yeah there we go i think
that's good enough pretty much
um and so we can now replace this other
one down here
span
x
class equals guess
letter
and in
word
class
comma
cool
so that now our legend
matches
there's a little bit of like i don't
like
this is butting up against that uh so we
can fix that pretty easily
because we know that we have this
result div
so we could just say let's put padding
on that thing too so
padding is 15 pixels that should give us
15 pixels of space
cool
so that looks pretty good
um
i think
right now this
input stuff is above it but in the
actual
wordle it's below it so we should
move it down so we'd say
text input it should be
as simple as just
dropping it down there
reload app
cool we still have this so maybe we want
to put it beneath that too
cool
it's looking pretty good
i think
um
i really want
this go button to be next to it instead
of beneath it um
so
um actually you know what maybe first we
will right now everything's shoved up
against the left of the screen but i
think that's a little bit
maybe not
at the best
so we want to
basically make everything sit in the
center
you know on a phone it'll be
like it is now but on a big screen like
the viewer right here
that's not ideal but to do that we need
to go back into the
html and i'm gonna see what the like how
we're going to target this whole app so
we have
the body of the thing and then we have
this div that div contains the whole app
and its class is containing your fluid
which makes sense because we're using
this fluid page
here
and so what we can do is target this
container fluid class and just give it a
maximum width
and that should
keep things nice and centered so it's a
container
fluid
fluid
and then
max
you know let's start with width width is
500 pixels
so now things are like pretty much in
the center which is nice
that's the nice thing fluid page
will automatically keep itself centered
which is nice um if it didn't we would
have to
control
that
the problem that we run into
is um
that
will cause issues and so
we don't actually want width we want
max width
and so maxwell says like you know follow
the video the width of the page you know
like the width of your iphone screen or
your computer screen
unless that's bigger than 500 pixels so
most of the time that's going to be
bigger than 500 pixels but in the case
where it's smaller it will let it shrink
at least in theory
so let's just see if that
does what i said it would
so yeah it's shrinking now it's not
letting itself get too big so that's
nice
so cool it's looking pretty
good right now i think one thing we
might want to do is
this board
uh
screen is not centered i'm just going to
give ourselves
some
context this helps to like
view what's going on in the app so we
can decide if something is centered so
it's not centered
so
we could try to make a centered uh and
that's
justify
content
this is another one of those you have to
look it up a million times
i gotta write on the first guess i i've
almost never done that
uh if you look at that css grid cheat
sheet there's like a bunch of different
ways to
align
the things in your
uh grid and
yeah so here we go so justify and
uh you can justify yourself you can
justify items
um
so
you get lucky basically almost no one
ever remembers it um but i got lucky and
remembered it there so
now this is lined up which the way that
it should be so that's good
let's do one more guest just to make
sure
cool it's working how it should that's
nice
i think the last thing that i want to do
is fix this
input so that the input is the go button
is here because we're just kind of
wasting space
so to do that like we had before we had
the
letters that just stacked on top of each
other it's because they're just this
block
setup we don't actually
let them know that we want them to be
next to each other
and so
we can group them together just by
wrapping them in a div so i could say
div this is just an eli
bring them up into that div
so this shouldn't change anything right
now it didn't so they're still right
there
let's give this to the class so that we
can start targeting it with our css
say
input wrapper
make sure that we're
take that input wrapper
down here dot input wrapper
outline
one pixel solid
let's do
[Music]
just deforest green
there's only so many css colors i can
keep in my head
cool so now we see that we do have this
div
there and we have the individual
elements within it
so
like we did before we could do display
grid
see what that gives us
does not exactly do what we might want
um
but
let's
do a different
way
let's do display flex and flexbox is
another layout algorithm
now they're next to each other flexbox
is basically
if you want to line things up next to
each other and make them align in the
proper way flexbox is what you want to
use
um
so that this is kind of a perfect
scenario for flexbox
so
a couple things stand out as not good
right now one is the go button is really
tall
compared to this
so and then also they're right up next
to each other i don't think we want them
next to each other
so let's do that same
way of selecting a child so we could say
input wrapper and then
button which is the
element selecting a button element we
could just say
margin left give it something like 10
pixels
so in theory that should take this
button and
basically make it 10 pixels from the
thing that it's closest to on the left
i did so it's nice
so that's better but now i don't like
that they're
like this um at all that's kind of gross
so
what we can do
is go into our browser's dev tools
because
just like css grid css flexbox has all
sorts of fun
settings that no one ever remembers but
the dev tools within chrome
have a nice little tool for working with
them
so you can do things like
align your content and you just play
with this little thing right here
and make it look like you want it to so
let's do
that centered it so say justify content
space around align content
doesn't do anything for us so we can
kind of just ignore it
align items centers now they're like
pretty close to being centered
um
so i'm going to copy this
css from here
put it here so i don't forget it because
i will forget it
quickly make sure that it works
okay it did
let's go back in here again that looks
pretty good but if you're like me you're
gonna get driven insane by the fact that
this button is not actually
lined up with
um
the input and that the text input
and that's because
you can see that there's this like weird
there's a margin on the bottom of that
input that is not on the bottom of the
button and so that causes it to be
misaligned
and so
what we can do
is since we already have something
targeting the button
go back in here look at this that's it's
a
shiny input container form group it's a
div
so
what we can do is say like let me get
in my input wrapper
div so this is saying i'm going to
target the div that is a child of
input wrapper so that should be this
text input and we could just say margin
bottom is zero
don't need to put like pixels or
anything because zero doesn't need units
reload it
and now it sticks there
so at least it's lined up on the bottom
um
i think we do align items
flex and
miss
okay
so flex n says in your vertical
alignment of these items in this box
um put it at the end you have to pre
prefix it with flex here because of
older browsers need that newer browser
you could just say end but
they also understand flex then so it's
safe to put that there
so now we pretty much got what we want
they're lined up how we want them
and then
we can
actually justify content space around is
not what we want because we already
spaced those things out so let's put it
justify content as center
so now they're centered the button the
space that we already did with our
margin is there
so that's nice and then we just got to
get rid of this like there's a space on
the top of this but not on the bottom
so we dealt with that before by putting
padding on it so let's just say
heading we only need padding on the
bottom here
cool
then take out this outline
and
okay let's see one
tests
that is looking pretty
decent
oh we gotta fix the kind of
get rid of that one outline
that i was so eagerly adding
that
helps to actually look at it how it will
be
just to make sure that there's not some
weird
css funkiness going on so that's pretty
good
i think the thing that i would do
next
is these colors are not right that like
orange red is like very like in your
face aggressive
so
i just go and
use this handy dandy css inspector tool
that i've been using
go to the world app
daily word game
and so we see that these are the colors
and we can just do that inspect element
and then
background color var
color correct but there's an easier way
to grow colors or
some might say steel
colors
so we use this you see this little
eyedropper
that i dropped over something it'll show
up the color right there we can copy
that
so forest green gets placed by this hex
color
and then
the gray that he uses is
this hex color
and last this is hardly an orange it's
more like golden rod maybe
use that
reload it that looks correct so
cool i think that's
pretty good
um
maybe one thing that we could do is make
the text bold so font wait
bold make it pop out a little bit
more kind of gets lost as a
and
cool i think that that
gets us
pretty far we can you know we could
tackle this keyboard but we would
basically just repeat the same
steps that we did for this
[Music]
you